Aaron is with us in Washington DC
hi Aaron how are you I'm good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up yes my question is I am in the
process of doing baby SEP - but I have a
situation wondering whether I should do
baby step 3 and slow down my debt
snowball because my roommate of three
months queer job about two month ago
only has no financial backing and I just
got the emergency fund not too long ago
but it's not enough and that is my
question that I am posing to you know we
never skip baby steps what we might do
in some situations is push pause on your
Total Money Makeover completely and pile
up cash because you have an emergency so
baby step 1 is $1,000 you have that
right right okay and then the roommate
is not paying bills she is but I don't
know how long she'll be covered because
she's still currently looking for I'm
swimming yeah how she paying the bills
now she has help from a friend of hers
okay and we don't know how long that
will go on right I could just stop
tomorrow mm-hmm okay and so she has
plans to move if she is not able to pay
the bill right all right all right
mmhmm yeah okay does you get you're not
a position subsidized ER you're broke
right okay just making sure we have a
clear understanding yeah I totally
understand you cool all right and so
yeah we push pause and meaning we're not
going to do any of the Total Money
Makeover right now we're just going to
pile up cash we got to get an umbrella
because we looked out the window and
there is a big black cloud and that's
what you're worried about
okay so I want you to just pile up cash
as high as you can pile it I don't care
how high how much debt do you have not
counting your house I don't have a house
I just have two phones a car and a
credit card so how much that's roughly
about 65,000 and what is your income and
it's got sixty six thousand roughly okay
cool all right
so uh if you were to save everything you
could save and you've already stopped
your 401k right correct good and you
pile up everything you can pile up how
much can you save a month if you just
really really are scared so you're
living on beans and rice and you're
getting ready for this storm that you
think's coming I think because I mussels
decided to do a second job I could get
like 500 a months if I stopped
everything that I'm doing yeah you
probably need more than that
yeah you need to stop more things that
you're doing okay yeah I need you to
save at least a thousand a month but
let's say you do that for like how long
are you gonna let her stay without
paying oh she's paying she's okay I know
when she stops paying how long are you
gonna let her stay without paying I will
give her about 30 days okay and so then
you would do what you'd get a new
roommate yes if that's possible I'm
still kind of skeptical be quite honest
because I wasn't expecting to be in a
situation why are you so mean why would
you not get on the roommate um
I guess maybe I just having a problem
with trusting people
but what's that'll move right right okay
so yeah I mean cuz if you can't pay the
bill without a roommate
you got a move or you got a roommate
it's a it's a math thing right right
okay so we'll have to find somebody we
can trust and we'll have to I mean this
girl's not lacking in trust she just
lost her job so she quit her job oh well
then I'm lacking in trust okay all right
so um you just walk out the door can't
pay your bills all right not smart all
right so uh yeah so anyway we're going
to get a roommate or we're going to move
so you're not going to need a ton of
money because this isn't going to go on
for very long are you under a lease or
month-to-month
monka month okay I'm sorry I'm under at
least when does it run out it burns out
next July August actually next August
okay so you're going to be getting a
roommate if she leaves mm-hmm okay so
the only question then is how quickly
you can get a roommate in there that you
can trust
right and so that's the whole so she
quits paying the next day you start
looking for a roommate within 30 days
she you get her you get a room made easy
you have to UM and so what does she pay
she pays roughly around a thousand with
rent and utilities and cable so you're
short a thousand for a month mm-hmm so
this crisis amounts to a thousand to two
thousand dollars maximum mm-hmm you
follow my analysis yes I do okay so
that's what you need fast-fast
you already got a thousand so we need
another thousand fast and so yeah stop
you're dead snowball and let's build up
you know two or three four thousand
dollars but then as soon as the crisis
passes and you have a new roommate or
this roommate gets a job and stays one
or you know but when the potential
crisis passes then you take any money
above a thousand and you throw it at
your debt snowball and you push play
again on your Total Money Makeover and
you get back after getting out of that
again does that make sense yeah and they
said you won't lose any ground is my
point you might lose a little bit of
interest for one month or something but
it's a-you know very little difference
on on the on the actual dollars here
it's just a matter of you just need this
pad you need this umbrella because you
know we've got this stinking storm
coming that's what it amounts to no fun
at all I'm sorry you're going through
this
hey guys Rachel Cruz here hope you
enjoyed that video from the Dave Ramsey
show if you want to watch another great
video check out my video three things
you should consider renting right over
here or click the link in the
description below
you